and klose and the event ok
comics extensions diakhate deadline of
british in orderly withdrawal from the
united kingdom it has been daily and that remains
the objective
if the united kingdom wants to get out in an orderly way
the only tool the only way is  this
treaty on the orderly withdrawal that
we negotiated together is agreed
together the withdrawal treaty was
not re-negotiable would not be reopened
it will not be the
political declaration which sets the framework for the future
relationship it can be improved
the demands that  we hope that we
expect from the uk side in the
framework of this dialogue to the parties will have to
respect the principles which are those of
the european council of the european parliament
respect what we are and what
we will remain
[Music]